what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we can't down the top five
characters teams and concepts from
across geek culture and this week we're
counting down my top 5 favorite moments
from the history of Dragon Ball Z number
5 kaio-ken vs. Gallic gun so initially
the Cheetahs arrival came out of his
desire to capture the Dragon Balls on
earth and wish for immortality
originally depicted as brash arrogant
and extremely proud Vegeta's first fight
with Goku was as much about good versus
evil as it was about the Prince versus
the popper while Vegeta viewed himself
as the prince of the Saints despite the
fact that the race was all but extinct
his desire for power arose from
expectation rather than need on the
other hand Goku had spent his entire
life training making friends and facing
wildly difficult enemies relative to his
own strength furthermore because his
training and understanding of the world
stemmed from his wives but now deceased
grandpa Gohan Goku strength lies in the
fact that he desires to prove his worth
as a warrior but also protect those
around them with these polar symptoms
clashing during a Saiyan saga of Dragon
Ball Z the resulting battle between Goku
and Vegeta gives us the desperate
attempt for each individual to overcome
the other Goku uses as Kyle can maneuver
in conjunction with the Kamehameha waves
to overpower Vegeta's Galligan attack
with Goku proving to be victorious and
their initial scuffle number 4 Goku's
teleportation kamehameha so the cell
saga was known for a lot of different
things the introduction of mr. Satan
Krillin falling in love with an Android
and Goku pulling off the greatest
maneuver in the history of the world
during the Cell games with Goku and
cells starting off the tournament to
determine the fate of the world goku
took to the skies and prepared to launch
the kamehameha with everyone watching
the fear was that Goku would make a dumb
decision and blow up the planet right at
the last moment though
Goku teleports in front of cell and
launches the kamehameha blowing off the
top of his body while cel would go on to
regenerate himself
this maneuver gave us the idea that Goku
is a fighter of many talents and is able
to use his creativity in conjunction
with his abilities to produce some
spectacular effects
number three Vegeta's final flash the
silverback was sell again but this time
we're switching over to Vegeta and prior
to the start of the Cell Games and
immediately following cells absorption
of Android 18 giving him his perfect
form Vegeta pulled out all the stops in
an effort to blow him up after reaching
his assented Super Saiyan form and
mustering everything he had he spent two
episodes pulling all of his energy
together and fired it off into a single
blast that blew off the top of cells
body
what made this scene so cool was that in
truth I think would you'd have
recognized that he was at fault for cell
reaching his perfect form to be honest
here it was Vegeta's arrogance that
allowed this to happen the cell preyed
on the Judas desire to fight as a true
warrior and go to Vegeta into allowing
him to absorb Android 18 and so I always
felt like Vegeta's final flash was an
act of desperation after he realized his
mistake and the fact that he had
essentially guaranteed the destruction
of the world number two Vegeta speech to
Goku
so this was an emotional moment as much
as anything else the following the death
of a cheetah at the hands of Frieza
allowing Goku to take center stage this
scene was so awesome because it was the
moment that Goku stepped into his
heritage of the sand race and while he
may have continued to consider himself
an earthling he came to the realization
that to defeat Frieza wasn't just about
saving earth his friends or the universe
it was also about avenging a race of
warriors pushed to the brink of
extinction in addition to this it give
us a glimpse into how did you defeat
both his Saiyan heritage and Goku in
that to him it was more about the pride
of their race the greatness of what they
could have become and keeping that
perspective alive Goku had died during
his fight with Frieza or in some
capacity walked away from his say in
history it would have meant that the
Saiyan race was truly dead number 1
Dohan turned super saiyan so I always
felt like Gohan turning Super Saiyan was
my favorite moment in the whole series
the reason why I was a combination of a
bunch of different things the music the
moment
Goku saying that the power comes of
response to a need not a desire all of
it came together to make this amazing
moment that had Gohan reaching back to
his history throughout DBZ and realizing
that when it came down to crucial
moments his fear always won out
and forego Han this was a turning point
and March's transition from someone who
depended on his
- bail amount - someone who could deal
with his own situations in truth it was
a rite of passage with a saying saga
Gohan ran off when he was supposed to
help defeat not but resulting in the
deaths of his friends in the Nanak saga
his fear kept him from tapping into his
true abilities and allowed the ginyu
force to overwhelm himself and his
friends and so pushing all of it aside
and realizing that the world was quite
truly depending on his success
Gohan smashed through the barrier and
became a Super Saiyan with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and let me know what other top 5
Dragon Ball Z moments you guys would
wish for me to cover and I will catch
you guys later peace